ladies and gentlemen i'm making this as
a public service announcement because
i've seen a lot of talk about robin hood
and uh their ceo vlad aka
vlad the stock impaler according to elon
musk vlad the stock impeller
hey guys thanks for uh thanks for
inviting me up
it's good to hang with all of you all
right what really happened
now there's a lot to unpack here but
basically the main thesis of this video
is that you cannot trust robin hood to
tell the truth
now that's not to say that i'm not
telling you to go move all your money
i'm not telling you all that
i personally if i if i had the app i
would delete it most of my money is in
just vanguard funds i'm not invested in
the gme situation
but i want to make this video because i
think a lot of
news coverage they just focused on the
now
and they don't really push the ceo of
robin hood to explain anything further
so far he's been given pretty easy
questions
by a lot of reporters where he's
constantly saying
oh yeah we decided to stop you know stop
trading because we couldn't handle uh
the clearinghouse requests
but then people ask oh do you have a
liquidity problem and he says no no
no no no no liquidity problem it sounds
to me though that you're suggesting that
there was a liquidity problem
inside the firm and my question about
that then raises all sorts of new
questions about whether there's a
systemic issue
uh underneath the system and underneath
the company unto itself
no no there was no liquidity problem so
that's the thing we're supposed to trust
this guy that we know very little about
and i want to reveal some facts
about his history just to contextualize
you know
whether you want to leave your money in
the hands of this guy or not because i
think this is important right
basically he's asking you to trust him
trust me guys i would tell you if
something nefarious was happening
trust me guys i would be honest with you
don't be don't go speculate because
trust me so you have to ask well who is
vlad
who is the ceo of robinhood well his
parents were uh
and i kid you not you cannot make this
stuff up they worked for the world bank
okay so he's not some poor kid who
decided to
democratize brokerage services
robin was started five years ago by
pioneering commission free
no account minimum mobile investing and
we've been
the spokesperson of the individual
investor and our whole goal as an
institution
is to enable those customers empower
them
and give them access to the markets
right he comes from the
elite of the elite but and this is the
bigger deal
just in december right so not like
two months it's still fresh on the mind
he actually got a cease and desist from
the
securities and exchange commission you
guys are gonna absolutely lose your mind
when you see this
in this document and in the press
release they described how
robin hood financial misled its
customers about revenue sources
and failing to satisfy the duty of best
execution now
they had to pay a big fine 65 million
dollars but
what's more interesting is not that they
had to pay a little slap on the wrist
fee because that's really what 65
million dollars
is to a company that has as much cash
flow
um as robin hood but why this is a big
deal
is the actual charge was that robin hood
lied to its customers let me repeat that
robin hood which right now the ceo is
asking you to trust him
that nothing nefarious happened with a
bunch of interested hedge funds that
they work with
they lie to you what did they lie about
well they lied about the way they made
money isn't that interesting they lied
about who they were
beholden to well you see robin hood
makes a huge amount of money
through something called order flow
right payment for order flow it's
controversial practice
um we're not going to get into it too
much here but basically
because they make their commission zero
they have to make their money somehow
right they're going to screw you somehow
and so they instead raise the price for
that the bid ask spread
raises up so you're actually on stocks
you're not the commission is basically
in the spread
i don't know if that makes sense whereas
normally someone would charge you
like a like a flat fee maybe instead
here
you've got your a higher bid-ask spread
and so you lose money
now that's how robin hood makes its
money is by these payments okay
but they lied about it and they didn't
tell their customers that's how they
were making money they misled you
in order to trick you into thinking that
80
of their revenue through 2015 and 2016
was from payment for order flow but
while they initially had it as a way
they made money
they deleted the payment for order flow
faq
robinhood kept no records of showing
when the payment for order flow was
deleted why it was deleted or who is
responsible for approving
its removal although payment for order
flow remained the company's largest
revenue source robinhood did not
include it as a way they made money and
so let me repeat that
they lied to you about how they made
their money
and they got punished for this as late
as december 17th of
2020 and then they want to tell you a
month later
the ceo of robinhood wants to get on
there and tell you hey we're all for the
customer
we're for the poor people we're about
democratizing financial services
when you lied to these customers you're
supposedly helping
about the fact that the real way you
make money is by just raising the bid
ask spread
the real way you make money is by
charging payment for order flow
charging higher rates than any of the
other brokers while
saying that you maintain competitive
rates for example for an order of more
than a hundred shares the analysis
concluded that robin hood's customers
would be better off trading at another
broker dealer despite
zero commissions because the additional
price improvement that such orders would
receive at other broker dealers would
likely exceed
the five dollar per order uh commission
cost that those other broker dealers
were then charging so i don't want to
get two in the weeds here but basically
the
the headline statement is robin hood
asks you to
trust them that nothing nefarious is
happening a month
after getting penalized millions of
dollars
for lying to their customers about where
the money was going
and who they were beholden to that's
what we're supposed to
believe the guy whose daddy and mommy
work at the world bank we're supposed to
believe that
he's got it out for your best interest
this is what's crazy i feel like
we live in looney tune land that
nobody's bringing this up
how's nobody bringing up the fact that
robin hood
just got charged a fee about this what
are we doing these people
look fool me once shame on me or
shame on you shame on you fool me twice
shame on me i don't know it's
unbelievable why would you lie to people
about how you made your primary source
of money ask yourself that and then ask
yourself
is that where you want to stick your
money with those guys who
lied to you and got punished for in 2020
you want to go stick that your money
with them and keep your money with them
all right guys that's basically it and
don't forget guys this is the month of
market manipulation that means if you
want to drop a like you want to drop a
comment you don't want to drop a share
we're trying to move the needle on
coffeezilla get us into the
recommendation
algorithm build up a better world of
content for you guys
uh so if you want to be a part of that
only february only you can't do it in
march you can't like the channel in la
march you can't subscribe in march
just join now join now that's all i'm
saying be a part greatest opportunity of
our era
so thanks for watching uh that's it and
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
wake up and smell the coffee